se faire opérer de la main comme quand
on va chez le dentiste c'est
l'innovation proposée par le centre de
chirurgie externe dédié à la main
yvelines sud
cette structure en expérimentation
située à montigny le bretonneux a été
lancée en juin 2020 par les docteurs
christian couturier et françois bruche
où on a constaté que beaucoup
d'interventions en chirurgie de la main
pouvait se faire avec des anesthésies
beaucoup plus légère que ce que l'on
fait habituellement avec un circuit
beaucoup plus court et que
l'hospitalisation n'était pas nécessaire
on fait des interventions exactement
dans les mêmes conditions de sécurité
avec la même technicité que dans un bloc
opératoire
cette innovation s'inspire du modèle
anglo saxon appelée office surgery le
patient reste peu de temps dans la
structure il vient et repart du centre
comme si c'était une consultation
médicale
toutes les pathologies de la main ne
sont pas concernés alors on opère le
canal carpien les doigts arceaux les
tendinites de carvin les petites tumeurs
les kystes les maladies dupuytren simple
les tendinites par exemple où coulent
les épicondylite on peut libérer des
nerfs superficielle quand ils sont
coincés à l'avant bras ou autour du
coude
cette pratique chirurgicale est rendu
possible grâce à une technique
d'anesthésié locale
la méthode wallon c'est finalement une
anesthésie locale avec des produits
vasoconstricteur ce qui fait qu'on n'a
pas besoin de garrot pour faire la
chirurgie le produit vasoconstricteur
fait un garrot chimiques et empêche le
saignement pendant l'opération
au programme de cette matinée un
syndrome du canal carpien ou encore le
déblocage d'une main on a le nerf médian
qui est coincé dans un petit tunnel qui
s'appelle le canal carpien à l'entrée de
la main et donc
on va couper ce ligament pour écarter
les berges du ligament et donner de la
place aux nerfs qui a écrasé en dessous
tendez la main
allez-y à fond et voilà
oui on a le résultat immédiat c'est
quand même gros intérêt de cette méthode
ce centre de chirurgie externe est
développé en collaboration avec l'agencé
régionale de santé d'île de france
il bénéficie d'un support technique
provenant de l'hôpital de rambouillet de
nouveaux outils devraient venir
compléter le projet comme un masque de
réalité virtuelle donner aux patients
pendant l'opération